I could fit all movies ever made inside
of this tube if you can't see it that's
kind of the point
before we understand how this is
possible it's important to understand
the value of this feat all of our
thoughts and actions these days through
photos and videos even our fitness
activities are stored as digital data
aside from running out of space on our
phones we rarely think about our digital
footprint but humanity has collectively
generated more data in the last few
years than all of preceding human
history big data has become a big
problem Digital storage is really
expensive and none of these devices that
we have really stand the test of time
there's this nonprofit website called
the Internet Archive in addition to free
books and movies you can access webpages
as far back as 1996 now this is very
tempting but I decided to go back and
look at the Ted websites very humble
beginnings as you can see it's changed
quite a bit in the last 30 years so this
led me to the first ever Ted back in
1984 and it just so happened to be a
Sony executive explaining how a compact
disc works now it's really incredible to
be able to go back in time and access
this moment it's also really fascinating
that after 30 years after that first Ted
were still talking about digital storage
now if we look back another 30 years IBM
released the first-ever hard drive back
in 1956 here it is being loaded for
shipping in front of a small audience it
held the equivalent of one mp3 song and
weighed over one ton at $10,000 a
megabyte I don't think anyone in this
room would be interested in buying this
thing except maybe as a
actors item but it's the best that we
could do at the time we've come such a
long way in data storage devices have
evolved dramatically but all media
eventually wear out or become obsolete
if someone handed you a floppy drive
today to back up your presentation you'd
probably look at them kind of strange
maybe laughs but you'd have no way to
use the damn thing these devices can no
longer meet our storage needs although
some of them can be repurposed all
technology eventually dies or is lost
along with our data all of our memories
there's this illusion that the storage
problem has been solved but really we
all just externalize it we don't worry
about storing our emails and our photos
they're just in the cloud but behind the
scenes storage is problematic after all
the cloud is just a lot of hard drives
now most digital data we could argue is
not really critical surely we could just
delete it but how can we really know
what's important today we've learned so
much about human history from drawings
and writings and caves from stone
tablets we've deciphered languages from
the Rosetta Stone you know we'll never
really have the whole story though our
data is our story
even more so today we won't have our
record recorded on stone tablets but we
don't have to choose what is important
now there's a way to store it all it
turns out that there's a solution that's
been around for a few billion years and
it's actually in this tube DNA is
nature's oldest storage device after all
it contains all the information
necessary to build and maintain a human
being but what makes DNA so great well
let's take our own genome as an example
if we were to print out all three
billion ace t's c's and g's on us
no standard font standard format and
then we were to stack all of those
papers it would be about a hundred and
thirty meters high somewhere between the
Statue of Liberty and the Washington
Monument now if we converted all those
A's T's and G's to digital data to zeros
and ones it would total a few gigs and
that's in each cell of our body we have
more than thirty trillion cells you get
the idea
DNA can store a ton of information in a
miniscule space DNA is also very durable
and it doesn't even require electricity
to store it we know this because
scientists have recovered DNA from
ancient humans that lived hundreds of
thousands of years ago
one of those is Otzi the Iceman turns
out he's Austrian he was found high
well-preserved in the mountains between
Italy and Austria and it turns out that
he has living genetic relatives here in
Austria today so you one of you could be
a cousin of it see the point is that we
have a better chance of recovering
information from an ancient human than
we do from an old phone it's also much
less likely that we'll lose the ability
to read DNA than any single man-made
device every single new storage format
requires a new way to read it we'll
always be able to read DNA if we can no
longer sequence we have bigger problems
than worrying about data storage storing
data on DNA is not new nature's been
doing it for several billion years in
fact every living thing is a DNA storage
device but how do we store data on DNA
this is photo 51 it's the first-ever
photo of DNA taken about 60 years ago
this is around the time that that same
hard drive was released by IBM so really
our understanding of digital storage and
of DNA have co-evolved we first learned
to sequence or read DNA and very soon
after how to write it or synthesize it
this is much like how we learn a new
language
and now we have the ability to read
write and copy DNA we do it in lab all
the time so anything really anything
that can be stored as zeros and ones can
be stored in DNA to store something
digitally like this photo we convert it
to bits or binary digits each pixel in a
black and white photo is simply a 0 or a
1 and we can write DNA much like an
inkjet printer can print letters on a
page we just have to convert our data
all of those zeros and ones to a is t's
c's and g's and then we send this to a
synthesis company so we write it we can
store it and when we want to recover our
data we just sequence it now the fun
part of all of this is deciding what
files to include so we're serious
scientist so we had to include a
manuscript for good posterity we also
included a $50 Amazon gift card don't
get too excited it's already been spent
someone decoded it as well as an
operating system one of the first movies
ever made and a pioneer plaque some of
you might have seen this it has a
depiction of a typical apparently male
and female and our approximate location
in the solar system in case the Pioneer
spacecraft ever encounters
extraterrestrials so once we decided
what sort of files we want encode we
package up the data convert those zeros
and ones to a is t's c's and g's and
then we just send this file off to a
synthesis company and this is what we
got back our files were in this tube all
we had to do was sequence it this all
sounds pretty straightforward but the
difference between a really cool fun
idea and something we can actually use
is overcoming these practical challenges
now while DNA is more robust than any
man-made device it's not perfect it does
have some weaknesses so we recover our
message by sequencing the DNA and every
time data is retrieved we lose the DNA
that's just part of the sequencing
process we don't want to run out of data
but luckily there's a way to copy the
DNA that's even cheaper and easier than
seek then synthesizing
we actually tested a way to make two
hundred trillion copies of our files and
we recovered all the data without error
so sequencing also introduces errors
into our DNA into the a's t's c's and
g's Nature has a way to deal with this
in our cells but our DNA is stored
you know our data is stored in synthetic
DNA in a tube so we had to find our own
way to overcome this problem we decided
to use an algorithm that was used to
stream videos when you're streaming a
video you're essentially trying to
recover the original video the original
file when we're trying to recover our
original files were simply sequencing
but really both of these processes are
about recovering enough zeros and ones
to put our data back together and so
because of our coding strategy we were
able to package up all of our data in a
way that allowed us to make millions and
trillions of copies and still always
recover all of our files back this is
the movie we encoded it's one of the
first movies ever made and now the first
to be copied more than 200 trillion
times on DNA soon after our work was
published we participated and it asked
me anything on the website reddit if
you're a fellow nerd you're very
familiar with this website most
questions were thoughtful some were
comical for example one user wanted to
know when we would have a literal thumb
drive now the thing is our DNA already
stores everything needed to make us who
we are it's a lot safer to store data on
DNA in a synthetic DNA in a tube writing
and reading data from DNA is obviously a
lot more time-consuming than just saving
all your files on a hard drive for now
so initially we should focus on long
term storage
most data are ephemeral it's really hard
to grasp what's important today or what
will be important for future generations
but the point is we don't have to decide
today there's this great program but
UNESCO called the memory of the world
program it's been created to preserve
historical materials that are considered
a value to all of humanity
items are nominated to be added to the
collection including that film that we
encoded while a wonderful way to
preserve human heritage it doesn't have
to be a choice instead of asking the
current generation us what might be
important in the future we could store
everything in DNA storage is not just
about how many bytes but how well we can
actually store the data and recover it
there's always been this tension between
how much data we can generate and how
much we can recover and how much we can
store every advance in writing data has
required a new way to read it we can no
longer read old media how many of you
even have a disk drive in your laptop
never mind a floppy drive this will
never be the case with DNA as long as
we're around DNA is around and we'll
find a way to sequence it archiving the
world around us is part of human nature
this is the progress we've made in
digital storage in 60 years
at a time when we were only beginning to
understand DNA yet we've made similar
progress in half that time with DNA
sequencers and as long as we're around
DNA we'll never be obsolete thank you
you